[Musica]
[Applauso]
credo che questo sia stato l'ultimo
suono che mio padre ha sentito cinque
anni fa prima di decidere di togliersi
la vita con un colpo di pistola al cuore
sì
probabilmente forse il gesto più di
rottura che lui ha commessi in tutta la
sua vita perché era in realtà un
ingegnere edile 110 e lode cavaliere del
lavoro e quindi per me per come lo
conoscevo io un gesto assolutamente
controcorrente rispetto a quello che
erano stati i suoi insegnamenti
ricordo che nell'ultimo periodo e negli
ultimi mesi insomma della sua vita in
salotto a casa sua c'era appeso questo
quadro non so se lo vedete se si vede e
ricordo che mi chiese che cosa ci
vedesse io dentro no e gli risposi
dicendo ma papà è un campo di grano con
dei corvi
illuminato e solo col tempo dopo sono
riuscito a capire che che mi stava
dicendo qualcosa mi stava dicendo
qualcosa di importante che io in quel
momento non ho capito io su questo
quadro ci tornerò alla fine e ve lo
spiegherò alla fine dopo un percorso una
storia che vi racconto e la storia di
come
sono stata cresciuta e delle scelte che
ho fatto le scelte che ho fatto le ho
fatte per dei motivi e l'ho capito forse
sempre in questi ultimi anni in cui mi
sono successe tante cose diverse
però risale tutto quando sempre mio papà
avevo 7 8 anni mi metteva in macchina mi
portava in giro e poi facciamo questi
viaggi mesi in macchina europa dell'est
inghilterra tutta l'europa l'america
abbiamo sempre viaggiato dai miei sette
otto anni fino ai 14 15 ma sempre
portato in giro
e e lì ho capito che cosa stava
succedendo succedeva che io lì lo
riempivo di domande in tutto il tragitto
e lui mi dava queste risposte infinite
perché mi sapeva tante di cose quindi
ero in qualche maniera affascinata da
tutto quello che lui mi stava
raccontando e i miei occhi intanto
guardavano conoscevano cercavano mi
stava insegnando ad essere curiosa
essere curiose a superare i limiti a non
accontentarmi di quello che stavo
vedendo ma ad andare a cercare la verità
a capire
credo che questo l'abbia fatto anche in
questo frangente era la festa di
carnevale uno dei ricordi più forti che
ho in cui io ero completamente in
disappunto come potete vedere dalla mia
espressione sul fatto che tutte le altre
bambine erano vestite da principesse da
fiori da fate avevano le corone invece
mio padre decide di vestirmi da piccola
romana in effetti non ero assolutamente
contenta di questo travestimento
però anche lì anche lì probabilmente mi
stava dicendo di non accontentarmi di
non essere uguale di cercare qualcosa di
diverso e credo credo poi di averlo
capito forse inconsciamente perché il
mio primo momento di rottura il mio
primo momento in cui ho applicato quello
che mi stava insegnando c'è uscire dalla
mia con ford non
andare a cercare qualcosa di diverso è
stato quando
nel passaggio no probabilmente quando si
sceglie dalle scuole medie si va alle
superiori avevamo già tutto deciso
contro la sua volontà naturalmente però
io devo fare la stilista e fare liceo
artistico poi quell estate proprio quell
estate in cui l'iscrizione era già stata
fatta
vedo un famosissimo film che era il
silenzio degli innocenti e decido che io
da grande avrei dovuto fare la
criminologa a tutti i costi quindi
creando un sacco di problemi alla mia
famiglia in quel momento perché le
scuole sono iniziando decidiamo di fare
tutt'altro percorso ma soprattutto lo
capisco
e capisco la necessità di uscire fuori
da questi schemi anche con la scelta
sportiva perché decido dopo variati i
passaggi di sport che ho scelto decido
lo sport della mia vita quello che mi
forgia quello che mi forma è quella che
che sono io oggi
tra poco ve lo dirò in realtà
quello che che mi lascia mi ha lasciato
mio padre era tutto scritto in un libro
che lui ha deciso di regalarmi ovvero la
necessità di trasformarsi di rinascere
nonostante i problemi della vita ed i
problemi negli ultimi anni ne ho messi
insieme parecchi lo sport che ho scelto
è stato il pugilato il pugilato
vent'anni fa pugilato femminile 20 anni
fa neanche esisteva e ricordo che io
insieme alle mie colleghe come si vede
in questa foto siamo state le prime
donne nel 2001 a fare i primi campionati
femminili
basti pensare che nel 2012 solo nel 2012
il pugilato femminile è diventato
disciplina olimpica con tutte le
difficoltà nel secondo e quindi le
palestre di pugilato prettamente
maschili la difficoltà di relazionarsi
soprattutto la difficoltà di dare
attendibilità al fatto che anche le
donne potessero fare del pugilato e del
buon pugilato
contemporaneamente porto avanti le mie
sfide professionali si le chiamo sfide
perché poi il pugilato per me diventa
una metafora di vita no l'ho
praticato per venti anni continua a
praticarlo ad esse ma la metafora di
vita è
che non esiste sconfitta nella vita
perché la sconfitta in realtà è un
momento di crescita un momento in cui ti
fa riflettere su che cosa è mancato e la
stessa cosa la pico anche nella mia
professione dove oltre a dei progetti
che seguivo in italia in carcere sono
arrivata a fare la criminologa però
sentivo sentivo che mi mancava qualcosa
allora iniziò a capire che quel qualcosa
che mi mancava era sempre quel quegli
occhioni fuori dal finestrino mentre
viaggiavo con papà scoprire nuove
culture nuovi posti di viaggiare quindi
unire ancora una volta la volontà di
guardare oltre quello che avevo davanti
e quindi inizia interessarmi alla
psicologia dell'emergenza
vado ad haiti
vado in nepal fino a che arrivò in un
luogo di cui mi innamoro che el india
l'india nasce in un momento della mia
vita un po particolare in cui la mia
carriera sportiva
era arrivata probabilmente ha dei buoni
traguardi perché ero diventata
campionessa italiana tre volte medaglia
di bronzo agli europei ero passata
professionista stata campionessa europea
e ho chiuso con un campionato del mondo
quindi tutto sommato ero assolutamente
soddisfatta
e quando arrivò in india mi occupo
esattamente delle stesse cose di cui mi
occupavo prima quindi raccolgo i bambini
dalla strada e me li porto in palestra
inizio insegnargli il pugilato invece di
lasciarli in mezzo alla strada
li prendo insieme a quella che diventa
come vedete in questa foto la mia
migliore amica indiana sonia in alto a
sinistra sogna la cito perché è quella
che mi ha fatto conoscere
ancora una volta un modello femminile
completamente diverso e molto piu
difficile rispetto a quelli a cui siamo
abituati noi
paese sony è stata una delle prime
pugili indiane in un paese in cui il
ruolo femminile
e marcato e sotto altri aspetti e
soprattutto sonia come vedete in basso a
destra e in basso a destra
in realtà il capofamiglia perché sonia
col suo lavoro permette di studiare le
due sorelle alle spalle e anche al
fratellino perché la mamma è morta e il
papa in pensione quindi e lei in realtà
che insegna a me come essere ancora più
forte e come mettere insieme quelle
battaglie quotidiane
per far sì che le cose funzionino anche
per una donna in un paese così difficile
mentre sono in india realtà viaggio
quindi passo anche dal nepal e nepal
collaboro con un'altra energie anche
l'incontro donne per esempio in alto a
destra erano delle donne sono rimaste
impresse che
facevano questo lavoro di trasportare i
turisti da una sponda all'altra di un
lago faticoso dove mi ha stupito la cosa
noi gli chiedevo come mai ma perché loro
volevano essere indipendenti avere anche
loro alla loro economia come delle donne
del kashmir con cui ho parlato in basso
a sinistra insomma vengo a contatto con
tutto quello che dei modelli femminili
completamente diversi rispetto a quello
che avevo conosciuto fino a quel momento
questo quando noi rientravamo perché
rientravamo in italia cercavo anche di
lavorare alle stesse cose in italia e
quello un po che cerco di insegnare come
vedete qua in questa foto alle mie
piccolini e quindi gilles de anna di sei
anni a cui insegno il pugilato e matilde
marta 14 15 ma in realtà non è il
pugilato che gli il segno
mi sono accorta che in realtà sto
insegnando a loro quello che è stato
insegnato a me da mio padre ad essere
curiose a non fermarsi a un ruolo
predefinito impostato fin dall'inizio a
cercare di riuscire a realizzare quello
che che in realtà loro vogliono per
esempio mi dà grossa soddisfazione
quando gilda o anna mi parlano del bullo
della classe mi dicono sai valeria siamo
riusciti a rispondere anche noi al bullo
della classe non ci ha paura beh è
permesso è una piccola soddisfazione
perché sono gli stessi insegnamenti con
cui io sono cresciuta
questo velo messo giusto per capire più
o meno anche a numeri che cosa succede
nel pugilato ma anche in tanti altri
sport però vi parlo del pugilato perché
io vi ho parlato del 2001 come i primi
campionati femminili di pugilato in
italia ma in realtà il trend sta andando
a scemare perché questa è la tendenza
degli stati uniti dove il pugilato a a
parecchi soldi a parecchie disponibilità
ma è un po un trend che si ripete anche
in europa in italia nel nostro paese dal
2008 fino ad oggi in realtà le donne
sono anche in questo campo purtroppo
diminuite ecco perché è il lavoro con le
bambine fin da piccola in realtà
in tutto questo naturalmente
alle mie spalle con me accanto a me
nelle mie scelte c'è sempre stato il mio
compagno il mio compagno che fabiano e
che vedete in questa foto fabiano
è l'ennesimo mio momento di rottura
perché lasciamo da amici migliori amici
al liceo cresciamo insieme ci fidanziamo
decidiamo che la nostra vita ci va
stretta in italia ci va stretta proprio
come vi ho raccontato prima decidiamo di
partire per l'india insieme io mi occupo
delle mie cose e lui delle sue
purtroppo dopo cinque anni siamo
costretti a rientrare credo che la
maggior parte di voi un po questa storia
l'abbia sentita però io oggi ve la
voglio raccontare in maniera differente
perché perché fabiano resta cieco e 3 e
tetraplegico in un incidente al nostro
rientro
e quindi questo ci costringe a fermarci
in italia a fermarci in italia a milano
e soprattutto ci fa perdere quell idea
di vita più bella del mondo che noi
pensavamo di avere in realtà una vita
normalissima come tante altre persone
però per noi era la vita più bella del
mondo e si interrompe
si interrompe con questo incidente
e a quel punto io sono la di vinto la
sua testa
mi impegno e cerco di capire che se la
testa di fabiano non avesse funzionato
il corpo non avrebbe spinto non avrebbe
retto
quindi lo tranquillizzo e gli faccio
capire che la nostra vita sarebbe potuto
essere lo stesso la vita più bella del
mondo diversa da prima ma più bella del
mondo ugualmente portiamo avanti la
speranza per due anni per due anni e
decidiamo addirittura di intraprendere
un viaggio importante
comunque tutto il mondo della medicina i
dottori che interpellava molin avevamo
contro ma noi volevamo andare a tentare
di fare le staminali in che paese in
india per cui ci imbarchiamo in un
viaggio infinito complicatissimo ma che
sul momento non mi sembrava così
difficile basti pensare la difficoltà di
portare un paziente una persona
tetraplegica ceca su un aereo però
tentiamo il nostro viaggio della
speranza probabilmente della nostra
ultima speranza
e vedo che la sua testa insiste spinge
vuole andare quindi affrontiamo il
viaggio arriviamo in india e
contemporaneamente però l'ho convinto a
scendere lo stesso a goa nello stato del
gol dove noi vivevamo per incontrare i
nostri vecchi amici perché probabilmente
non li avrebbe mai più potuti rivedere
quindi prendiamo l'ambulanza da bombay
carichiamo tutto e ci facciamo 600
chilometri sulle strade indiane in
ambulanza
quando arriviamo giu si vede vedo
percepisco dal suo dalla sua espressione
che non è più la stessa cosa e
soprattutto lo percepisco quando
rientriamo quando rientriamo in italia
perché a quel punto anche solo la
piccola mobilità della mano che lui
aveva riacquisito la perde
ma a quel punto non perde solo quello
perde anche la speranza e allora mi dice
un'unica cosa mi dice valeria
tutti metteresti in questo letto legata
bendata
se ci dovessi stare quanto tempo
riusciresti a starci ha detto
probabilmente neanche cinque minuti le
ho risposto in quel frangente
allora lui mi ha detto ecco proprio da
questa risposta devi trovare la forza
per riuscire ad accompagnarmi in
svizzera e dire basta
io sono stata d'accordo con lui fin dal
primo momento perché il soprannome suo
era tarantella per me per i suoi amici
da quanto lui si muoveva da quanta
voglia di vita lui aveva e soprattutto
avevamo tutte e due
però decide di intraprendere una
battaglia è ancora una volta è il mio
ennesimo momento di rottura così non mi
andava bene non mi andava bene che per
lui il nostro stato per le nostre leggi
una persona non fosse libero di poter
scegliere che cosa fare della propria
vita di dire basta
non c'è più qualità non c'è più dignità
voglio farla finita
e allora fabiano decide di intraprendere
una battaglia una battaglia
per favorevole al suicidio assistito
favorevole a la libertà di poter
scegliere cosa fare
la propria vita
questo velo raccontato per farvi capire
che alla fine da dove sono partite al
volere è potere
se uno veramente vuole una cosa anche in
questa condizione anche con un viaggio
estremo come quello che abbiamo fatto lo
si può fare basta crederci fino in fondo
ma soprattutto continuare imperterrito a
combattere per la propria libertà
sempre e comunque
e allora torniamo al quadro all'inizio
io ritorna al quadro all'inizio
credo che quel quadro per mio padre
in realtà questo quadro è il quadro che
ha dipinto van gogh l'ultimo periodo
prima di spararsi un colpo alla testa e
per lui rappresentava la morte il suo
percorso di vita i corvi e la morte
all'orizzonte la fine
ecco per me questo quadro oggi non
rappresenta quello questo quadro oggi
per me rappresenta
quello che mi ha insegnato mio padre e
quello che mi porto dietro che la
curiosità è il mezzo con cui noi
riusciamo a superare qualsiasi tipo di
confine ma che soprattutto siamo nati
selvaggi e non dobbiamo permettere a
nessuno di darci degli schemi entro cui
stare ma dobbiamo essere sempre liberi
di poterci di scegliere
[Applauso]